AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT GAME.
BAPTISM BY FIRED.
JON STEWART IS LEAVING "THE
DAILY SHOW" THIS WEEK.
THIS IS THE END OF AN ERA.
THIS MAN CHANGED TELEVISION.
HE EVOLVED COMEDY. HE'S WON A
MILLION EMMYS.
HE'S DONE SUCH AN AMAZING JOB.
(APPLAUSE)
>> AND AS WE LOOK BACK AT
HIS LEGACY, ONE THING THAT
STANDS OUT IS HOW MANY
CAREERS HE HAS HELPED
LAUNCH.
NOT JUST THESE GUYS BUT SO
MANY OTHER PEOPLE.
AND ALSO, KIND OF MY CAREER
TOO.
THE YEAR WAS 2000.
JON WAS INTERVIEWING MY
FORMER "SINGLED OUT" CO-STAR
JENNY MCCARTHY, BEFORE
SHE UNDISCOVERED VACCINES.
AND I, BY THE WAY, WAS FAT,
DRUNK, HALF ASLEEP. MY LIFE
WAS COMPLETE [BLEEP] AND
THEN THIS CAME ON,
WHICH WAS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
SHOWS AT THE TIME.
AND THIS HAPPENED.
>> EVERYTHING IS GOING
AWESOME.
>> IT'S TERRIFIC.
AND IT'S FUNNY, CHRIS
HARDWICK WORKS HERE NOW.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> AND THE SHOW IS CALLED,
THE SITCOM WHAT IS IT
CALLED?
>> NO, NO, NO.
HE DOES THE COFFEE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> THIS WAS ONE OF THE MOST
DEFINING MOMENTS IN MY LIFE,
BECAUSE THIS WAS A PUBLIC
INTERVENTION, AND IT WAS THIS
ON TELEVISION WHEN I SORT OF
LOOKED AROUND AND SAW THESE
EMPTY PIZZA BOXES AND BEER
BOTTLES, I WAS LIKE OH,
[BLEEP], HE'S RIGHT.
AND PEOPLE LAUGHED.
AND THAT'S WHEN I REALLY
STARTED GOING, "HEY, I
SHOULD NOT DRINK AND GET MY
LIFE TOGETHER."
SO I OWE JON STEWART A HUGE
DEBT OF GRATITUDE FOR
ACTUALLY [BLEEP] ON ME IN
PUBLIC AND CREATING A HUGE
WAKE-UP CALL.
I'M FAIRLY CERTAIN IT WASN'T HIS
INTENTION TO HELP ME IN
ANY WAY BUT THAT WAS THE RESULT.
>> I HUNG OUT WITH PARTY
CHRIS HARDWICK.
HE WAS PRETTY AWESOME.
>> WE SHOULD BE MAD AT
JON STEWART FOR FOISTING YOU
UPON US.
>> YES, THIS DID GET ME
THINKING, WHETHER IT'S
MAKING COFFEE OR CLEANING UP
THE @MIDNIGHT GREEN ROOM
AFTER STEVE AGEE HAS BEEN ON,
WE'VE ALL HAD OUR FAIR SHARE
OF TERRIBLE JOBS.
COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO
LIST OFF THE WORST JOBS YOU HAVE
EVER HAD IN 60 SECONDS AND
BEGIN, AL.
>> GEORGE ZIMMERMAN SURPRISER.
>> HELMS.
>> DONALD TRUMP'S MINORITY
OUTREACH ADVISOR.
>> POINTS.
>> ED HELMS.
>> ROBOT HITCHHIKER.
>> POINTS.
>> BEAR WRESTLER, NOT THE
ANIMAL BUT BIG HAIRY GAY
MEN.
>> POINTS.
>> ROB.
>> ANAL BLEACHER ON A CRUISE
SHIP.
>> POINTS.
>> NOT SO BAD IF YOU USE FLEACH.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AL.
>> SUGE KNIGHT'S MECHANIC.
>> ALL RIGHT.